like would you have an abortion yourself
and do you think it should be legal
so then go ahead
um
no and yes
yeah I'm pro-choice
um I think it should be legal and I
would have an abortion
um
I am pro-life and I think it should be
illegal
go ahead
yes and yes okay
all right well you can't but
um but pro-life or pro-choice
I I think abortion is wrong okay so
pro-life yeah okay
um Pro Choice pro-choice
oh hi guys
um do you
um so today's topic is abortion and the
question is are you Pro what's your name
why don't you start with your name your
age and then are you pro-life or
pro-choice hi I'm Sunny I'm 25 and I'm
pro-choice
okay
okay
I'm taylor27 taylor27
um pro-choice okay
um so blessing you want to play the
first video
like
experience with abortion and I don't
think we talk about this enough abortion
can be another word for Mercy some 16
year old's life has been irrevocably
changed because of the current
overturning of Roe v Wade and what its
implications are what it means to live
in a country that puts us in this
position and when you are a young woman
starting out your career your
reproductive Destiny matter is a great
deal well nowadays I couldn't take that
for granted I couldn't take that freedom
for granted the freedom of choice we
know that no two pregnancies are alike
and it follows that no two lives are
like that follows that no two
conceptions are alike so how can we have
a law how can we have a point of view on
this that says we must treat everything
the same when you allow for choice you
allow for flexibility which is what we
need in order to be human this is not a
moral conversation about abortion this
is a practical conversation about
women's rights and by the way human
rights because women's rights are human
rights and the freedom that we all need
to be able to to choose and build our
lives and have access to excellent
Health Care
my own personal experience with abortion
and I don't think we talk
okay so what did you guys think of that
video so you can start and then go
around
yeah um
yeah I think it's it's sad because she's
talking about the woman but she doesn't
make any mention about the the child
there's another life there's two lives
involved when we're talking about
abortion and one life chooses to end the
life of that innocent human being so I
think she's just totally ignoring the
other human being in the equation
um I agree with what she said I think
abortion should be legal I think it's
the woman's choice if she wants to have
an abortion or not
um
yeah
um
I I
take it from the Viewpoint of
the fact that
we are
not just to consider
um
just the individual I feel like
human life
um has
or the woman has a choice the bait The
Unborn doesn't have a choice
um so
you know that should be factored in
because that is another human life as
well so yeah
I think it's incredibly Brave of her
firstly to actually speak up and discuss
a subject on such a large World stage
that is so judged and like for her to do
that is a big step for the freedom of
speech around this topic and has
literally opened up the floor for this
topic I think considering the life of a
child it has to be encompassed of who is
actually raising that child you know the
child isn't just born and then becomes
its own soul and its own being it's
raised by as a byproduct of what the
parent currently is and the pattern and
the and the blueprint that a parent has
created and if you haven't yourself done
the work to enable yourself to be the
best possible parent of only yourself
and your inner child
to then be expected to raise another
child would actually be
a discredit to The Unborn being I think
like
to become a parent is to know that
you're ready
to raise another being and consider that
actually you're passing on your
blueprint and if you still carry heavy
trauma then how can you raise another
being to its best possible
potential of Soul like
didn't I feel like people raised kids
with trauma all the time before yeah we
I think we all carry trauma to some
degree but if there's certain parts of
yourself that you haven't uh
eradicated or developed then like what
do you imprint that onto a child is that
quite a big thing okay go ahead yeah I
think age Gap um I'm sorry age is really
important when deciding whether to get
an abortion or not and um
she was pretty old that woman so she
yeah
I don't really think she knows what it's
like to be in a position of someone
that's younger that might need to get an
abortion you know
um
I think depending on the age it's got a
very big part to play in it if you're 17
18 you need to get an abortion because
you know you're not financially unstable
to look after that child
then yeah I mean
you've got to have it but then again
that all comes down to you know your
decision to like have sex at that age
you know and um at that age I don't
think people should be prioritizing this
type of things you know at like 17. yeah
so you feel like it's kind of their own
fault
yeah I had a lot of friends in Primary
School
um and then they went to secondary
school and they got pregnant at 17. and
they kept like three of three of my
friends don't know them but yeah now
they will have children maybe even four
now I think okay
go ahead
um yeah so personally I think obviously
Let's Get the facts out there that
obviously it is murder right killing an
unborn child is still murder
um and obviously it is a separate person
like people think oh it's my child
um or it's my partner's child but
actually it's a separate person
um so yeah like it is a fact however we
have a free will and we have a choice no
matter what people say no matter what
they do we still have a choice no one
can change us not the God not devil we
can only change ourselves and we have
that Free Will so whatever we decide it
should be our choice okay
um what about you two
um I see you talking
um I feel like like any challenge you
have to be ready for it if you're not
ready for it then
the results may go away is that you
can't even anticipate so I feel like the
circumstances that people are in before
they have a child should be taken into
account heavily when making such
decisions
um just the same kind of I don't think
you should bring a child into a
situation if they're going to be
resented
are unwanted
uh okay like just a quick question for
myself that's just been triggered is
like is it still classified as a human
being when it can't breathe on its own
um I mean I think that depends who you
ask yeah but like scientifically like if
you can't take your own breath are you
is it still classified
oh God yeah go ahead
um well from the from the point of
fertilization when the sperm and the Egg
meet that's scientifically the beginning
of a new human being start so that's
when we all our lives all began and then
you just need time to grow into a more
you know adult version of yourself so
that is when life begins so is it still
classified even though you're not
dependent on your own 90 of
um scientists say that life begins at
conception so I'm curious
um okay so for the people that are
pro-life so one two three it's a good
mixed panel today when do you so would
you guys say that abortion should be
outlawed
completely
you would say yeah if you see me if you
say yes raise your hand
you think it should be outlawed
completely okay for the people that are
pro-choice
um when how long up to abortion like
should abortion be legal to tell
um up to birth up to six months up to
three months
or if you've a different number but
those are the three most common answers
I seem to get go ahead I mean of course
not up until the day that you're like
gonna give birth but
I think the day that it's at now why is
it like 24 weeks or something yeah you
guys have six months also six months
yeah I think you know that the doctors
and people are saying six months is okay
then I think six months is okay okay I
mean personally I wouldn't have won you
know six months I would try and get as
done as early as possible but you know
six months then that's six months okay
at what point does it for like maybe
this is just my lack of knowledge but at
what point does it form
into
from a fetus to an actual being like
where is the form of the brain and like
where is the form of the heart like
where does that actual scientific
process like
uh transform
you know yeah University right
um well I mean development is an ongoing
process right so actually the heart
starts beating at around 21 days
um and so a lot of women don't even know
they're pregnant then
um and the brain waves around six weeks
at eight weeks uh the baby actually has
um the 90 of the same organs that we
that we have as adults
so it's actually very surprising wait
say that again though eight weeks eight
weeks from fertilization so eight weeks
if you think about it most women find
out they're pregnant you know maybe they
miss their period and they find out five
six six weeks or so I don't even know
that so eight eight weeks that baby that
all that embryo has
um yeah has 90 of the same organs that
you and I have at what point do we stop
like where's the transformation from
like embryo to fetus to baby I mean
these are just names so these are just
scientific terms so um the word fetus
just means little one in Latin and that
is from nine weeks we call it an embryo
from the verse point it's called a
zygote then we call it an embryo up to
um eight weeks and then from nine weeks
onwards it's referred to as a fetus when
that when that child's born it's now a
baby then it becomes a toddler then it
becomes you know child teen major adult
these are just stages of development
they don't say whether we're you know
how valuable we are we don't say you
know that a teenager is more valuable
than a toddler simply because it's older
because it breathes for itself
well a toddler Breeze for itself doesn't
it yeah so I'm saying that a teenager is
not more valuable than it is an embryo
doesn't breathe for itself right it's
required someone else's breath to
survive is that when you think that life
conception like so at Birth
I'm kind of unpacking this as we go it's
just kind of interesting actually yeah
I'm just asking it actually is something
that um I don't know your name which is
yes something that cassid was like oh
hang on a second like
at what point is it actually
still dependent on like my breath to
survive like it's it's not its own is it
a human like it made me think that is it
a human being yet because it's not
actually being on its own it has to
breathe through me it requires
everything from when I say me I'm
referring to the female reproductive
organs like it's not being its own human
at that point
it has to break through me and that got
me really thinking about the actual
stages of this process because I'm just
thinking like that argument then you
could abort it like a couple days before
you give birth
which which I I don't know about you I
think we'd agree that's that's a little
late yeah you know I mean I would agree
with you yeah yeah and so
um yeah that's that if we go by the
breath argument as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible